feel better already
[Music]
uh
wow
so
[Music]
uh
wedding preparations in full bloom
how
grand a beautiful and worthy celebration
my lord
thank you
set a spirited tone for east anglia's
future avor i'm so glad you've made it
just like you to keep a king waiting at
his own wedding
yet i arrived in the end a part of me
worried you wouldn't
[Music]
i told you i would see you crowned and
now here we are
without you i'd be dead
another wasted hope for east anglia
[Music]
you look good oswalt like a man about to
marry a more powerful woman
do i
because i'm nervous as hell of all the
battles a man can fight the war against
himself is the hardest to win
[Music]
my
foreign
[Music]
oh
i hereby name you man and wife this man
and wife i name you
[Music]
oswald of elmer
first of his name the rightful king of
east anglia
with his lady valdes soul fist
beauty of this land
[Music]
oh
you've done it stuart a king now sits on
the throne of east anglia
don't leave yourself out of this song we
did it together
back to your dreams then of fire and
helheim
i lost my way some time ago hard to say
one
i don't want to be here i never did
this was half dan's dream he ordered me
to see through
my dreams i'm sailing remember
wind in my beard salt on my lips
i want that life again
whether or not i find it only time will
tell
until then let us feast drink and forget
our pain
gaze upon my parts
they stand so strong
unbreakable at this distance no they are
not broke here my arrow shadow whatever
target they strike
even after draining so much meat
succeed and you shall be rewarded
keep your eyes open long enough to
witness me you drunken loud
a day
leading a saxon army and her brothers
too
she charged into battle without fear
yes that's it
password everything an easy task for the
wolf kissed
ah barely a challenge
impressive impressive
here as promised now go enjoy the party
your fist is without hail let us address
that
surely a special kind of metal is
required for drinking before the new
king a metal not unlike your own to odin
and his endless glories and the new king
of east anglia may his reign be long and
good
not bad wolf kiss
i wager you couldn't drink more than me
if you tried
a fool's wager
a challenge nonetheless what say you
i will drink you under the table
confident are you
let us see how you fare against the ale
beast of east anglia
and we'll make it interesting
put your silver where your mouth is what
say you
[Music]
silver such tiny ambition
do it for the skulls that will sing
songs of our superior bellies
then let our guts live forever in their
tales come let the making of a legend
begin
okay
[Music]
be kissing at flagstaff soon
easy
hey
[Music]
oh the ale here it's strong but i am
stronger
[Laughter]
i stronger than me
you drink as well as valdis now that i
would pay to see
look there winner on the roof the road
to valhalla does not run that way from
here he's been up for a while
these are the moves
heywood
some sweet wine for a sweet swine
come join me
the saxon god wander somewhere up here
does he not i haven't seen him they like
to say he moves with mystery
look the moon
it moves on trouble now
but one day it will be eaten by a giant
wolf and the knights will be black
forevermore
are you all right
i've tasted glory once again
and it was good
i'm glad to hear it now i always felt
like skull party
chasing and
trying to fulfill halfton's wishes but
now i've caught my sun and moon i've got
them and i
i don't know
you can let them go sail to a further
shore my long ships in valhalla
don't you remember
fire starter
come on let's get you to solid ground
everything's spinning
you're very strong
you're very large
[Music]
sorry for this abort
i've had one last glory
i should be happy
i am happy
thank you
it need not be the last
[Music]
the boar represents fertility
did you know that
esther's freyja what's your point
you impress me avor
your battle wisdom your strength of
character
skilled in so many ways yet i wonder
is there any skill of mine that i could
impress upon you
even a fool has something to teach
whether they're aware of the lesson or
not
hey hey
but i could show you how to wield my
plow sword
be plain about it stiff spear you want
to lay with me is that it that i do
will you follow me
to a place more comfortable
a good plow sword is a rare thing
lead the way
[Music]
so
gods
that's worth a verse or two in some
skull song
i'll remember that for all time avor
i shall as well growth here ruther
i'm not brutal
police balls you thought i was my
brother
to be honest i did not think at all
how strong he is how handsome
it's always proven bro evil i'm about to
address our guests and i'd like you to
be there
it has been a worthy ceremony so far and
have you had enough fun yet
i am ready to hear you address your
kingdom
good come come
join me
friends honored guests
we've pushed through hard times it seems
like all we've known is loss suffering
but it is not conflict that binds us it
is compassion may we always favor
compassion even when our enemies refuse
its boon
so to my dane friends and neighbors i
give thanks for the bravery you have
shown during our collective struggles
and for my fellow christians may we
continue standing as examples of our
lord's grace
lights in the dark i see east anglia's
future right here right now in all of
you dane and saxon alike
to our future
still a bit soft on insults but the king
has courage and to evil without whom
none of this would have been possible
on behalf of east anglia let this ring
be proof of our loyalty to the raven
clan and all they have done for us today
would you have any words of wisdom for
us
i am not one to bask in the glow of
another's triumph
but i will say this east anglia is safe
under his protection under his guidance
under his wing the good king oswald will
keep you safe for many moons to come
to oswalt
okay everyone the bridal race starts now
remember you all have to lose to the
bride and groom
quick brother we can't lose to oswalt
oh
[Applause]
you lost
[Music]
it was a beautiful wedding asphalt
like you said it would be
thanks to you and everything you've done
here
east anglia needed a leader i simply
helped put the right one on the throne
when we met i spoke of an alliance will
you hold to the oath you made i will
consider east anglia a friend of the
raven clan there will be a day when i
come calling
[Music]
goodbye friend
until next time great king
i should find vineyard say goodbye
before i leave
[Music]
ah greeting ever
you're missing the festivities
i've had my fill
it's as much yours as it is oswalds
i was a crumbling man abel
before all this i thought i'd die a
tired old failure
but now
my heart burns bright with newfound fire
i want to live hard die fierce
glory cares not for age
sail with me
my ship could always use a wise head and
a strong axe
together
i'll gather my things
guys